hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger qu'ellroy né au château de
dourdan a succédé à robert 2 à robert
hue quel droit vous m'aidiez le château
2 est né au château de dourdan et a
succédé à robert 2 quel roi de france ah
ouais attendait au chaud répondre un
instant vivent juste apparemment on
aurait une allocution du président de la
chaîne art aprikian on doit rendre
l'antenne
bien entendu roja c'est tabou
bonjour toute la journée les équipes de
cyril hanouna m'ont demandé de l'aider à
tricher au baccalauréat
sachez qu'il n'en est pas question d lui
dès qu'une chaîne sérieuse
le baccalauréat est une institution
importante et il est hors de question de
participer à cette mascarade
oui si aprikian gkp à l'accueil pour
vous lucas paix mais il en avance oui
bon on fait le monter qu'est ce que je
disais déjà oui pas de triche pour le
baccalauréat président c'est un
président intègre bravo à ras bravo vous
c'était quoi elle roiné au château de
dourdan a succédé à robert 2 oui alors
et a fondé une ligne et d'ailleurs je
pense à hugues capet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]